beete kann man nie genug haben oder wer
braucht schon rasen wenn der erdbeeren
oder tomaten haben können deswegen bauen
wir heute ein einfaches und stabiles
kasten hochbeet dass jeder hinkriegt
auch wenn man zwei so linke hände hat
was bauern angeht so wie ich du brauchst
für die langen außenseiten zwei bretter
die drei meter lang sind 28 cm breit und
5 cm stark dann für die kopfseiten zwei
bretter die genauso breit und stark sind
und ein meter 20 lang so dass das bild
ein meter 20 breit wird dann brauchen
wir für die ablage die oben drauf kommt
etwas dünnere bretter die sollen so
ungefähr 2 cm stark sein
die sollen beide ein meter 4 lang sein
und 13 cm breit dann brauchen wir noch
für die langen seiten genauso starke
bretter die auf 13 zentimeter breit sind
und drei meter lang und für die
stabilität brauchen wir vier kanthölzer
für die ecken die 28 zentimeter lang
sind und 6 x 6 cm breit und damit die
ablage auch schön stabil sitzt brauchen
wir noch mal zehn kanthölzer die auf 6 x
6 cm breit sind und 18 cm lang ich habe
euch das aber auch alles unten in die
video beschreibung geschrieben dann eine
sehr gefallen die ganzen sachen noch zu
sagen möchte ist ein zollstock ist nie
verkehrt bohrer zum vor bohren wenn du
das machen möchtest wir haben es gemacht
ist finde ich ganz praktisch schrauben
die einmal 80 millimeter lang sind und 1
x 50 mm lang und einen akkuschrauber
wir mussten leider fichtenholz nehmen
besser wäre lärche oder douglasie weil
die viel länger halten fichtenholz kann
man aber mit einem biologischen
holzschutzmittel auch ganz gut schützen
und wir haben die erfahrung gemacht dass
das holz dann trotzdem mindestens vier
jahre hält was immerhin schon mal etwas
ist aber wenn ihr die wahl habt nehmt
lieber douglasie
der liga der beete so an dass die ein
meter 20 und wenn man dann noch ganz gut
vom rand ins bett kommt durch in die
mitte alle arbeiten verrichten kann ohne
sicherheit zu verrenken so da irgendwie
im bett zu landen
aber wenn du merkst dass dir das zu
breit ist also kannst das ja mal
ausprobieren auf der wiese einfach mal
ein meter 20 abmessen und gucke ob du
noch überall hinkommt bis in die mitte
dann kannst du natürlich auch schmalere
beete anlegen dass es natürlich gar kein
problem es gibt auch den trend zu
schmaleren beten gerade im
marketingbereich da werden die beete
deutlich schmaler angelegt aber die ein
meter 20 bei uns total gut hin obwohl
ich gerade mal 1 meter 63 groß bin
hättet ihr das gedacht dass ich
vergleiche das kann man über video immer
gar nicht so genau sagen
wir starten erst mal mit dem großen
kasten der um unser bett rum kommt aus
den dicken bohlen und da nehmen wir die
28 cm langen kanthölzer und schrauben
sie außen an die schmaleren teile also
die vor kopf seiten unseres beetes ist
jeweils mit zwei schrauben so dass wir
da einfach eckpfeiler haben die das
ganze unterstützen und für das komplette
grundgerüst mit den dicken bohlen
brauchen wir die 80 millimeter schrauben
also die längeren schauen das hier sind
dann die aktuelle bleibst du die langen
seiten also die außenseiten des beetes
und schraubt die von außen an die kurzen
seiten dran so dass die eckpfeiler schön
zwischen den beiden blättern sitzen und
das ganze stabilisieren ich habe dafür
jetzt drei schrauben verwendet das ganze
wie gesagt vor geburt ich hab fleißige
unterstützung von meinem sohn die hat
das beet quasi ganz alleine
zusammengebaut nicht schlecht oder war
das grundgerüst steht jetzt schon mal
jetzt schrauben wir die latten obendrauf
die sind dafür da dass das ganze ein
bisschen stabiler ist und dass man auch
mal saatgut trittin und so weiter
ablegen kann das ist denke ich ganz
praktisch wenn da viel schnaps cds deine
dünneren bretter die kurzen kann
natürlich auf die kundenseite und die
lernen auch die langen
du siehst dass sie zu den unteren
brettern versetzt sind und die schraube
ich jetzt ungefähr alle 40 50 zentimeter
mit einer schraube fest das ist auch vor
geburt und dafür nehmen wir jetzt die
kürzeren schrauben also die 50 cm
schrauben weil die blätter eben nicht so
dick sind obama noch nicht so lange
schauen
[Musik]
ja und jetzt machen wir die kleinen
plätzchen die brauchen wir damit das
ganze stabiler wird damit man sich auch
mal auf die bildränder setzen kann und
das ganze nicht gleich zusammenbricht
dass man auch mal eine voll gefüllte
gießkanne drauf stellen kann und dann
bringe ich an den langen seiten jeweils
drei kätzchen an und an den kurzen
seiten jeweils zwei kätzchen die das
aufliegende brett stützen
dafür verwenden wir auch wieder die
lange schrauben weil die klapse lebens
ihm wichtig sind wenn du probleme mit
wühlmäusen hast das einmal um und
befestige da einfach einen guten
kaninchendraht also einen hochwertigen
den du auch ganz oft überall festmacht
bis keine maus darunter schlüpfen kann
es könnte sein dass die mäuse schaffen
in die beete reinzuspringen ich sage
eigentlich immer ab 40 cm bieten muss
man sich da keine sorgen mehr machen
unser bild ist nicht mal 30 zentimeter
hoch deswegen weil sie nicht ob das
klappt aber mit dem draht machst du den
wühlmäusen das leben auf jeden fall
schon mal entscheiden schwerer so dass
sie es nicht so leicht haben die ganzen
gemüse weg zu räumen
das bild kann man jetzt zum beispiel mit
kompass erde auffüllen wir besorgen uns
die immer ganz gerne im kompostwerk weil
wenn man die im baumarkt kaufte dann ist
die erstens in plastiktüten eingepackt
das macht enorm viel müll und im
kompostwerk wenn die erde lose kaufte
ist ja auch viel viel günstiger außerdem
kannst du unten auch stöcke reinpacken
und misst das funktioniert wie so eine
fußbodenheizung verrottet nach und nach
oder auch und verrotteten kompost oder
altes laub was noch irgendwie fliegt
aber wenn ihr wollt dass ich euch mal
ganz genau zeige wie man so ein beet
befüllt dann schreibt das mal unten in
die kommentare weil da kann ich gerne
auch mal ein video für euch darüber
treten denkt daran wenn ihr mehrere
solcher kasten beete nebeneinander
aufgebaut dass ihr die so weit
voneinander entfernt hinstellt dass ihr
mit der schubkarre immer noch gut
zwischen den beeten dank fahren könnt
also den weg ruhig ein bisschen breiter
machen als man denkt weil das viel
praktischer denn mit der schubkarre
nicht mehr durchkommt ist es super
unpraktisch wenn man die beete zb
irgendwann wieder auffüllen will weil
die auch abflachen oder wenn man nur
große erntemenge abtransportieren will
die beete münchen will
so weiter also da immer darauf achten
dass noch genug platz zwischen den
beeten ist wenn die schiffe durch passt
passt auch der rasenmäher durch das ist
auch ganz praktisch ansonsten kennt ihr
auch holzhackschnitzel auf den wegen
zwischen ihren beeten ausbringen dann
müsst ihr nämlich überhaupt nicht mehr
mähen um dazwischen einen weg anzulegen
und dann kannst du auch gleich los
pflanzen wenn du dein bett befüllt hast
da kannst du dir entweder einen fertigen
pflanzplan herunterladen wenn du nicht
so genau weiß wie es mit der mensch
kultur in der fruchtfolge unter den
anbau pausen und so weiter funktioniert
dann lad ideen gerne herunter den link
findest du in der video beschreibung
oder du schaust hier drüben in dem video
vorbei da zeige ich dir nämlich schritt
für schritt wie das funktioniert mit dem
anbau plan und am ende ist der verdammte
am hubland fertig also geh raus und
mache die welt ein bisschen grüner wir
sehen uns am samstag wieder biss dann